ברוכים השבים להבנת מידע קוונטי וחישוב. שמי John Wattress ואני המנהל הטכני לחינוך ב-IBM
Quantum. זהו השיעור ה-16 והאחרון בסדרה והנושא של השיעור הוא חישוב קוונטי עמיד
בתקלות. במהלך שלושת השיעורים הקודמים, ראינו כמה דוגמאות לקודים לתיקון שגיאות קוונטיות שיכולים לזהות ולאפשר לנו
לתקן שגיאות קוונטיות כל עוד לא מתרחשות יותר מדי מהן. אם אנחנו רוצים להשתמש בתיקון שגיאות לחישוב קוונטי, עם זאת, יש עדיין הרבה
בעיות שצריך להתמודד איתן, כולל המציאות שה-gate-ים הקוונטיים שלנו, המדידות, והכנות
המצבים שלנו עצמם כנראה לא מושלמים. אז, למשל, אם אנחנו הולכים לבצע תיקון שגיאות על
qubit אחד או יותר שקודדו באמצעות קוד לתיקון שגיאות קוונטיות, אז נצטרך לעשות את זה עם gate-ים ומדידות שבעצמם
יש סיכוי שלא יעבדו נכון. וזה אומר לא רק כישלון בזיהוי או תיקון שגיאות, אלא אולי גם
הכנסת שגיאות חדשות. בנוסף, אנחנו גם צריכים לבצע את החישובים בפועל שמעניינים אותנו שוב עם gate-ים שהם לא
מושלמים. ובטוח שאנחנו לא יכולים להסתכן בפענוח מידע קוונטי לצורך ביצוע חישובים ואז
לקודד מחדש כשנסיים כי שגיאות עלולות לפגוע כשההגנה של קוד תיקון שגיאות קוונטי לא קיימת.
זה אומר שאנחנו חייבים להבין איך לבצע gate-ים קוונטיים ישירות על qubit-ים לוגיים שאף פעם לא נשארים בלי
ההגנה של קוד תיקון שגיאות קוונטי. זו משימה לא קלה, אבל ידוע שכל עוד רמת הרעש
יורדת מתחת לערך סף מסוים, זה בעצם אפשרי לבצע חישובים קוונטיים גדולים ככל שנרצה בצורה אמינה באמצעות חומרה רועשת, לפחות
בתיאוריה. ונדון בעובדה הקריטית הזו בהמשך השיעור. הנה סקירה קצרה של
השיעור. נתחיל עם מודל בסיסי לחישוב קוונטי עמיד בתקלות כולל דיון קצר
על מודלים של רעש יחד עם מתודולוגיה כללית למימוש circuit קוונטי בצורה עמידה
בתקלות. לאחר מכן נעבור לנושא של התפשטות שגיאות ב-circuit-ים קוונטיים עמידים בתקלות ואיך
לשלוט בזה. בפרט, אדבר על מימושי gate טרנסוורסליים שמציעים דרך פשוטה מאוד לשלוט בהתפשטות
שגיאות. למרות שיש מגבלה יסודית שמונעת מאיתנו להשתמש בשיטה הזו
באופן בלעדי. אדבר גם על מתודולוגיה אחרת שכוללת מה שנקרא מצבי קסם שמציעה דרך אחרת לשלוט בהתפשטות
שגיאות ב-circuit-ים קוונטיים עמידים בתקלות. למרות שזו לא השיטה היחידה הידועה ולבסוף השיעור
מסתיים עם דיון ברמה גבוהה למדי על משפט הסף שרמזתי עליו לפני רגע.
המשפט הזה קובע ש-circuit-ים קוונטיים גדולים ככל שנרצה יכולים להיות ממומשים בצורה אמינה כל עוד שיעור השגיאה של כל הרכיבים
המעורבים יורד מתחת לערך סף סופי מסוים. באופן כללי, ערך הסף הזה
תלוי בקוד תיקון השגיאות שאנחנו משתמשים בו וגם בבחירות הספציפיות שלנו למימושים עמידים בתקלות של
gate-ים קוונטיים ומדידות אבל לא בגודל ה-circuit שאנחנו מממשים. וזה נותן לנו סיבה טובה להאמין שחישובים קוונטיים בקנה מידה
גדול יהפכו יום אחד למציאות. נתחיל בדיון על מודל בסיסי לחישוב קוונטי עמיד
בתקלות שמבוסס באופן טבעי על circuit-ים קוונטיים וקודים לתיקון שגיאות קוונטיות. לצורך הדיון הזה,
בואו נדמיין שיש לנו circuit קוונטי שאנחנו מקווים לממש כמו זה שמוצג כאן. זה במקרה
circuit של טלפורטציה כולל הכנת ה-EBIT. אבל הפרטים הספציפיים לא ממש חשובים לדיון הזה. ואתם יכולים לדמיין ש
זה כל circuit קוונטי אחר, אולי circuit הרבה יותר גדול שכולל הכנות מצבים, פעולות
יוניטריות, ומדידות. ה-circuit הזה, כמובן, מייצג אידיאל, ומימוש
בפועל שלו לא יהיה מושלם. השאלה הטבעית לשאול היא מה יכול להשתבש
פה? ובכן, יש די הרבה דברים שיכולים להשתבש. למשל, אתחולי המצבים בדרך כלל לא יהיו
מושלמים. כמובן, ה-gate-ים היוניטריים לא יהיו מושלמים וגם לא
המדידות. ויותר מזה, ה-qubit-ים עצמם יהיו רגישים לרעש, כולל דה-קוהרנטיות, בכל נקודה
בחישוב, אפילו כשלא קורה שום דבר ל-qubit-ים האלה והם פשוט מאחסנים מידע קוונטי. במילים אחרות, כמעט
הכל יכול להשתבש. יש חריג אחד בכל זאת או לפחות זו הנחה טיפוסית ו
זה שכל חישוב קלאסי שמעורב כנראה לא יהיה פגום כי לכל דבר ועניין
חישובים קלאסיים הם בעצם מושלמים. אז למשל, אם אנחנו מריצים אלגוריתם התאמה קלאסי כדי
לחשב תיקונים לשגיאות של קוד משטח, אנחנו באמת לא צריכים לדאוג שהחישוב הקלאסי הזה עלול להיות פגום. אבל כל דבר שישירות
מערב מידע קוונטי יכול להיות. כמובן, אנחנו צריכים מודל מדויק שדרכו אנחנו יכולים לשייך
הסתברויות לדברים שונים שיכולים להשתבש. ואם היינו רוצים, יכולנו לבנות מודל מורכב ככל שנרצה בתקווה לשקף את מה ש
באמת קורה במציאות. אם המודל מורכב מדי, עם זאת, הוא עלול להפוך לקשה או בלתי אפשרי לעבוד איתו או לומר
משהו מעניין עליו. דוגמה פשוטה מאוד למודל רעש שאנשים מתחשבים בו לעיתים קרובות
היא מודל הרעש הסטוכסטי הבלתי תלוי שבו שגיאות או תקלות המשפיעות על רכיבים שונים ברגעים
שונים או במילים אחרות, מיקומים שונים ב-circuit הם בלתי תלויים.
למשל, אנחנו יכולים לומר שכל gate נכשל בהסתברות מסוימת, שהיפוכי ביט והיפוכי פאזה קורים ל-qubit-ים מאוחסנים בהסתברות
שונה ליחידת זמן וכן הלאה. אבל ההנחה היא שאין קורלציה בין שגיאות
שונות. עכשיו, אתם עלולים להתנגד למודל הזה כי כנראה יהיו קצת קורלציות בין
שגיאות. למשל, כנראה יש סיכוי קטן לשגיאה קטסטרופלית שמוחקת את כל ה-qubit-ים בבת אחת.
או אולי יותר סביר, יכולות להיות שגיאות שהן מקומיות אבל בכל זאת משפיעות על מספר רכיבים.
ואף אחד לא טוען אחרת. אבל בכל זאת, המודל הזה מייצג קו בסיס פשוט שב
מהותו מייצג את הרעיון שהטבע הוא בלתי צפוי, אבל הוא לא זדוני והוא לא מנסה בכוונה
להרוס חישובים קוונטיים. יש מודלים ריאליסטיים יותר של רעש שלעיתים קרובות מתחשבים בהם. וללא קשר ל
מודל שאנחנו בוחרים, אם מתברר שהמודל שלנו מוליך אותנו שולל ואנחנו לומדים משהו חדש על השגיאות ב
כל מערכת שאנחנו עובדים איתה, אנחנו יכולים באופן טבעי לנסח ולשקול מודלים שונים של שגיאות. בשלב הבא,
נסתכל על אסטרטגיה בסיסית למימוש circuit-ים קוונטיים בצורה עמידה בתקלות. אז בואו נשקול circuit
קוונטי לוגי נתון, כלומר circuit קוונטי אידיאלי שאנחנו מעוניינים להריץ. למשל, נוכל לשקול את אותו circuit כמו
קודם, שעכשיו נמתח קצת כי אנחנו הולכים להצטרך קצת יותר מקום למימוש העמיד בתקלות שלו. קודם כל
הכנות המצבים, ה-gate-ים היוניטריים, והמדידות לא יבוצעו ישירות כ-gate-ים בודדים או כ
מדידות של qubit בודד או הכנות מצבים, אלא הם יבוצעו על ידי מה שנקרא גאדג'טים, ש
כל אחד מהם יכול לכלול מספר qubit-ים ומספר פעולות. כאן בתרשים הזה,
המחשתי את זה על ידי ציור קופסאות סגולות מסביב לדברים האלה. ואתם יכולים לחשוב על הקופסאות הסגולות האלה כמו circuit-ים קטנים או פעולות ש
פשוט מסומנים לפי הכנת המצב או ה-gate שאנחנו מתכוונים לממש. שנית, אנחנו צריכים להגן
על ה-qubit-ים באמצעות קוד תיקון שגיאות. אז זה לא יהיה ה-qubit-ים הלוגיים עצמם שמחברים את הגאדג'טים השונים, אלא הגאדג'טים פועלים על
ה-qubit-ים הפיזיים שמקודדים את ה-qubit-ים הלוגיים האלה. וחשוב להדגיש כאן שה-qubit-ים הלוגיים שאכפת
לנו מהם אף פעם לא חשופים, כלומר ה-qubit-ים הלוגיים האלה יבלו את כל חייהם מוגנים על ידי כל
קוד תיקון שגיאות קוונטי שאנחנו משתמשים בו. ולבסוף, אנחנו מבצעים תיקון שגיאות על ה-qubit-ים המקודדים שלנו
שוב ושוב לאורך כל החישוב, בעצם בכל הזדמנות. וזה קריטי מאוד שאנחנו עושים
את זה. באופן אינטואיטיבי, כשגיאות מתרחשות, אקראיות או אי-ודאות מתחילה להצטבר במצב של
ה-qubit-ים שלנו ואנחנו צריכים לעבוד כל הזמן כדי להסיר את האקראיות או האנטרופיה הזו. וזה קורה דרך תיקון שגיאות.
אז אתם יכולים בערך לחשוב על צעדי תיקון השגיאות האלה כמו מקררים לוגיים קטנים או משאבות חום ש
מאפשרים ל-qubit-ים הלוגיים להישאר קרים כדי שהחישוב יוכל לעבוד כמו שצריך.
ברגע שכל הבחירות האלה נעשו, כלומר הבחירה של כל הגאדג'טים וגם הקוד ובהנחת מודל רעש מסוים, יש
שאלה יסודית שאנחנו יכולים לשאול את עצמנו והיא, האם זה באמת עוזר. האם אנחנו משפרים את המצב או
מחמירים אותו? אם יש יותר מדי רעש, אנחנו בהחלט יכולים להחמיר את המצב,
בדיוק כמו שקוד Shore של 9 qubit-ים מחמיר את המצב אם הסיכוי לשגיאה גבוה מדי.
אבל אם הרעש מתחת לסף מסוים, אז כל העבודה הנוספת הזו תוביל אותנו למקום טוב. וכפי שנדון לקראת סוף השיעור,
נפתחות דרכים להפחתה נוספת של השגיאה. בחלק הזה של השיעור, נדון בהתפשטות שגיאות ב-circuit-ים קוונטיים עמידים
בתקלות שיש להם את המבנה הבסיסי שתיארתי הרגע. מתברר שזו
דאגה עיקרית כי אם לא נצליח לשלוט בהתפשטות שגיאות, שגיאות יציפו במהירות את מאמצי תיקון
השגיאות שלנו. אבל אם נצליח לשלוט בהתפשטות השגיאות, אז הקוד שלנו יעמוד בסיכוי הרבה יותר טוב
להדביק כדי ששגיאות יתוקנו בקצב גבוה מספיק שיאפשר לחישובים שלנו
לעבוד. נקודת המוצא לדיון הזה היא ההבנה ש-gate-ים של שני qubit-ים או gate-ים של מספר qubit-ים באופן
כללי יותר יכולים להפיץ שגיאות גם כשהם עובדים כמו שצריך.
למשל, שקלו gate מסוג C-not. ונניח ששגיאת X מתרחשת על ה-qubit השולט לפני ביצוע gate ה-C-not
. ובכן, שגיאת X מתפקדת בדיוק כמו gate מסוג X. ואנחנו מגלים ש
ה-circuit משמאל שקול לזה שמימין שבו שגיאות X מתרחשות על שני ה-qubit-ים אחרי ה-C
-not. זו התפשטות של שגיאות כי המיקום הרע של שגיאת ה-X משמאל הופך אותה למעשה
לשתי שגיאות X מימין. ואנחנו לעולם לא נעקוף את זה. כל עוד אנחנו משתמשים ב-gate-ים של C-not, תמיד יהיה
סיכוי ששגיאת X תתרחש על ה-qubit השולט ממש לפני, שאז מתפשטת לשתי שגיאות X
אחרי. אבל כפי שנראה, כל עוד אנחנו נוקטים צעדים להגביל את הנזק שזה גורם, נהיה בסדר. ודרך אגב,
אותה תופעה מתרחשת כשיש לנו שגיאת Z על ה-qubit המטרה ממש לפני C-not. ודיברנו על זה
קודם ואתם יכולים לבדוק את השוויונות האלה פשוט על ידי ביצוע הכפלים או שאתם יכולים לבדוק אותם באמצעות
Qiskit. השורה התחתונה היא שזה יגרום בשני המקרים לשגיאות מתואמות על מספר qubit-ים. וכמובן אנחנו
לא צריכים לשכוח שגם gate-ים של C-not עצמם יכולים להיות פגומים מה שגם יכול לגרום לשגיאות
מתואמות. מה שמוסיף לדאגה שלנו, gate-ים עוקבים של שני qubit-ים עלולים להפיץ את השגיאות האלה אפילו יותר רחוק.
למשל, אם יש לנו שלושה gate-ים של C-not כמו אלה, בדיוק כמו שאנחנו מוצאים כשמודדים מחוללי מייצב X למשל, אז שגיאה בודדת יכולה
להתפשט במהירות למספר qubit-ים. ואם זה קורה בתוך בלוק קוד יחיד, למשל, כלומר חבורה של
qubit-ים שביחד מקודדים qubit לוגי, לכל קוד תיקון שגיאות שבחרנו לא יהיה
סיכוי כי קודים מתוכננים לתקן שגיאות במשקל נמוך, לא שגיאות במשקל גבוה כאלה.
ולכן זה משהו שאנחנו חייבים לזכור, ובעצם לשים בחזית, כשאנחנו חושבים על הגאדג'טים ועל
צעדי תיקון השגיאות ב-circuit-ים קוונטיים עמידים בתקלות. הדרך הפשוטה ביותר הידועה לצמצם התפשטות שגיאות ב-circuit-ים
קוונטיים עמידים בתקלות היא לממש gate-ים בצורה טרנסוורסלית ואסביר מה זה אומר
עוד רגע. אז בואו נשאיר את האיור של המימוש העמיד בתקלות שלנו על המסך בתור עזר ויזואלי.
הרעיון כאן הוא שעבור חלק מהקודים לתיקון שגיאות קוונטיות, gate-ים מסוימים יכולים להיות ממומשים בצורה טרנסוורסלית, מה ש
אומר לממש אותם באמצעות גאדג'טים שהם מכפלות טנזור של פעולות כאשר כל פעולה פועלת רק על
מיקום qubit יחיד בתוך כל בלוק קוד. הכי קל להסביר את זה דרך כמה דוגמאות. הדוגמה הראשונה וה
פשוטה ביותר היא מימושים טרנסוורסליים של gate-ים מסוג Pauli.
הרעיון הוא שנרצה לבנות גאדג'טים לכל אחד מה-gate-ים ב-circuit שלנו. ובכל המקרים, הגאדג'טים האלה
פועלים על בלוקי קוד כמו שאנחנו רואים עבור gate-ים של X ו-Z בסוף ה-circuit של הטלפורטציה שלנו. כמובן, אנחנו
לא יכולים לפענח, להחיל gate מסוג Pauli, ואז לקודד מחדש כי זה ישאיר qubit לוגי חשוף ושגיאות
עלולות להתפשט בתוך בלוק הקוד כתוצאה מקידוד מחדש.
למזלנו, אנחנו לא צריכים לעשות את זה כל עוד אנחנו משתמשים בקוד מייצב כי כל קוד מייצב מאפשר לפעולות Pauli
להיות מוחלות ישירות על ה-qubit-ים הלוגיים שלנו. ולמעשה, אנחנו יכולים לעשות את זה עם מכפלת טנזור של gate-ים מסוג Pauli
על ה-qubit-ים הפיזיים שמשמשים לקידוד.
למשל, אם נשקול את קוד המשטח 3x3 שעלה בסוף השיעור הקודם, אז נוכל לממש gate-ים של X ו-Z על ה-qubit
הלוגי שמקודד בקוד הזה על ידי שילוב ביחד של gate-ים של X ו-Z יחד עם gate-ים של זהות בתבניות ש
מוצגות כאן. זהו מימוש טרנסוורסלי של ה-gate-ים האלה כי כל אחת מפעולות ה-gate
הבודדות האלה פועלת רק על מיקום qubit יחיד בתוך כל בלוק קוד.
אנחנו משתמשים רק ב-gate-ים של qubit יחיד כאן, אז זה קצת טריוויאלי בדרך מסוימת, אבל בכל מקרה, גאדג'טים כאלה לא יגרמו לשגיאות
להתפשט. עכשיו, כל אחד מה-gate-ים הבודדים בגאדג'ט כזה יכול להיכשל, וזה יכניס
שגיאות, אבל תמיד נבצע תיקון שגיאות מיד אחרי כל גאדג'ט. וכל עוד שיעור השגיאה
נמוך מספיק, קוד תיקון השגיאות יתקן את השגיאות האלה.
וכמו שאמרתי, זה תמיד אפשרי עבור gate-ים מסוג Pauli לכל קוד מייצב.
אם כי צריך לזהות את התבנית הנכונה של gate-ים מסוג Pauli בגאדג'טים כדי לממש כראוי כל פעולת Pauli לוגית שאתם מכוונים
אליה. לדוגמה נוספת שכן כוללת gate-ים של שני qubit-ים. הפעם נוכל לשקול מימושים טרנסוורסליים
של gate-ים מסוג C-not. בפרט, לכל קוד CSS, אנחנו תמיד יכולים לממש gate מסוג C-not
בין שני qubit-ים לוגיים פשוט על ידי ביצוע gate-ים של C-not על זוגות מתאימים של qubit-ים
פיזיים. וזה עומד בתנאי של להיות טרנסוורסלי כי כל אחד מ-gate-ים הבודדים האלה של C-not פועל רק
על מיקום qubit יחיד בתוך כל בלוק קוד. למשל, gate ה-C-not הראשון פועל רק על ה-qubit העליון ביותר
בתוך כל בלוק קוד. gate ה-C-not השני פועל רק על ה-qubit השני מלמעלה וכן
הלאה. במקרה הזה, יכולה להיות התפשטות של שגיאות כי gate-ים של C-not מפיצים שגיאות ואין
דרך למנוע את זה. אבל המפתח הוא שהתפשטות השגיאות אף פעם לא קורית בתוך בלוק קוד יחיד. למשל,
שגיאת X יכולה להתרחש על ה-qubit העליון של בלוק הקוד העליון ממש לפני שהגאדג'ט מבוצע וה-C-not הראשון
בתוך הגאדג'ט יפיץ את השגיאה ל-qubit העליון בבלוק התחתון. אבל שתי השגיאות שנוצרו
נמצאות עכשיו בבלוקי קוד נפרדים. אז צעדי תיקון השגיאות שמתרחשים אחרי הגאדג'ט יוכלו לתקן את השגיאות האלה בנפרד כי השגיאות
האלה משפיעות רק על qubit יחיד בתוך כל בלוק קוד.
לעומת זאת, אם התפשטות השגיאות היתה קורית בתוך אותו בלוק קוד, אז היינו עלולים להיות בבעיה כי
התפשטות השגיאות הופכת אז שגיאה במשקל נמוך לשגיאה במשקל גבוה יותר שהקוד שלנו אולי לא יכול להתמודד איתה.
המימוש הזה לא עובד עבור קודים שאינם CSS, אבל כל עוד אנחנו משתמשים בקוד CSS, אנחנו תמיד יכולים לממש gate-ים של C-not
בצורה טרנסוורסלית בדרך הזו. ולעוד דוגמה, כל
gate מסוג Clifford יכול להיות ממומש בצורה טרנסוורסלית עבור קוד Steane. ולמעשה עבור כל קוד צבע שזה אחד הדברים הממש נחמדים בקודי
צבע בפרט gate מסוג Hadamard על qubit לוגי יכול להיות ממומש על ידי ביצוע gate-ים של Hadamard בנפרד על
כל אחד מה-qubit-ים הפיזיים ו-gate לוגי מסוג S יכול להיות ממומש לא על ידי gate מסוג S על כל qubit אלא דווקא על ידי
gate מסוג S צמוד על כל qubit פיזי. אז השורה התחתונה היא שמימושי gate טרנסוורסליים הם מטבעם
עמידים בתקלות כי הם אף פעם לא מפיצים שגיאות בתוך בלוק קוד יחיד מה שנותן לצעדי תיקון השגיאות סיכוי להילחם ולתקן
את כל השגיאות שמוכנסות או מופצות על ידי ה-gate-ים שמשמשים לגאדג'טים האלה. אז זה מעולה וזו
דרך ממש פשוטה לבנות גאדג'טים עמידים בתקלות ויש קודים שונים שמאפשרים מימושים טרנסוורסליים של gate-ים שונים כמו
gate-ים מסוג T אבל למרבה הצער זה בלתי אפשרי עבור כל קוד לא טריוויאלי לממש קבוצה
אוניברסלית של gate-ים בצורה טרנסוורסלית שזו עובדה הידועה כמשפט Eastin-Knill בניסוח טכני יותר מה ש
הוא אומר הוא שכל עוד לקוד שלנו יש מרחק לפחות שתיים הקבוצה של gate-ים שיכולים להיות ממומשים בצורה טרנסוורסלית בהכרח תייצר
קבוצה דיסקרטית של פעולות עד לפאזה גלובלית ולכן הקבוצה הזו לא אוניברסלית כי קבוצות gate
אוניברסליות בהכרח מייצרות אינסוף פעולות. לא אסביר את ההוכחה של המשפט הזה שמשתמשת בכמה
עובדות בסיסיות על חבורות Lie ואלגברות Lie שאינן דרישות מוקדמות לסדרה הזו. אבל הרעיון הבסיסי הוא
שמשפחות אינסופיות של פעולות טרנסוורסליות לא יכולות לשמור אותנו בתוך מרחב הקוד כי הבדלים זעירים
בפעולות טרנסוורסליות מקורבים היטב על ידי פעולות Pauli במשקל נמוך שהקוד מזהה כ
שגיאות. אז אנחנו מאוד שמחים כשאנחנו יכולים לממש gate-ים בצורה טרנסוורסלית. אבל לכל קוד שנבחר, אנחנו יודעים שתמיד
יהיו לנו gate-ים שאנחנו לא יכולים לממש בדרך הזו. ולכן אנחנו צריכים לחפש גאדג'טים חלופיים. לפי
משפט Eastin-Knill, אנחנו יודעים שזה לא אפשרי לממש קבוצה אוניברסלית של gate-ים קוונטיים בצורה טרנסוורסלית אפילו
עבור קוד תיקון שגיאות קוונטי עם מרחק 2 בלבד. אז אנחנו צריכים למצוא דרכים אחרות לממש gate-ים בצורה עמידה
בתקלות לפחות עבור חלק מה-gate-ים. דרך ידועה אחת לעשות את זה היא דרך שימוש במה שנקרא מצבי
קסם. לצורך הדיון הזה, בואו ניזכר ב-gate-ים מסוג S ו-T שהם
gate-ים של qubit יחיד המוגדרים כפי שמוצג כאן על המסך. בואו גם נשים לב שראשית S הוא פעולת Clifford
שנובע מההגדרה שלנו לפעולות Clifford. אבל אתם יכולים גם לבדוק שצמידה של מטריצת Pauli על ידי S תמיד נותנת לנו פלוס או מינוס מטריצת
Pauli אחרת. ושנית, T הוא לא פעולת Clifford. ולמעשה, אם נשלב T עם Hadamard ו-C-not, ששניהם
פעולות Clifford, נקבל קבוצה אוניברסלית של gate-ים קוונטיים. אז אנחנו לא יכולים לממש gate מסוג T
באמצעות רק פעולות Clifford ומדידות בסיס סטנדרטי בלבד. אבל אנחנו למעשה יכולים לממש gate מסוג T באמצעות
פעולות Clifford ומדידות בסיס סטנדרטי אם בנוסף יש לנו עותק של המצב שמוצג כאן על
המסך, שזה gate מסוג T מוחל על מצב פלוס.
המצב הזה נקרא מצב קסם, אם כי הוא לא ייחודי בהקשר הזה.
המונח מצב קסם משמש גם להתייחס למצבים שונים שממלאים תפקיד דומה לזה שכאן בווריאציות של כל
הסכמה הזו. למשל, ה-circuit שמוצג כאן עושה את העבודה. ולא קשה מדי לבדוק
את זה. הנה המצב ההתחלתי עם המערכת העליונה מימין. ואם נחיל את gate ה-C-not ונפשט, נקבל את
המצב שמוצג כאן.
אז אם נמדוד את ה-qubit התחתון ונקבל אפס מה שקורה בהסתברות 1/2, אנחנו לא מבצעים את
ה-S gate והפלט הוא T מוחל על S.
ואם נמדוד אחד מה שגם קורה בהסתברות 1/2 כמובן אנחנו כן מחילים את ה-S gate והתוצאה הנטו היא
שהפלט הוא שוב T מוחל על S. זו לא הדרך היחידה לעשות את זה דרך אגב. יש circuit-ים דומים אחרים
שמשיגים את אותה מטרה אבל זו דרך אחת לעשות את זה.
זו דוגמה מפושטת קצת של משהו שנקרא טלפורטציה של gate קוונטי, שרמזתי עליה בשיעור 4, שבה טלפורטציה משמשת
לא לשלוח qubit-ים, אלא להפעיל gate-ים. הקשר לטלפורטציה אולי לא לגמרי ברור כאן כי, כמו שאמרתי,
זו גרסה מפושטת, שאנחנו יכולים להרשות לעצמנו בגלל ש-T היא אלכסונית. אבל אם מעניין אתכם
ללמוד עוד, מילות המפתח הן quantum gate teleportation.
ואפשר גם לעשות משהו דומה כדי לממש gate מסוג S, שבמקרה הזה ה-gate-ים היחידים שאנחנו צריכים הם C-NOT gate ו-Z gate יחד עם המדידה
וזה עוזר אם אין לנו מימוש טרנסוורסלי של S gate. אז זה מעניין אבל לא
לגמרי ברור שזה באמת עוזר. במקרה של מימוש ה-T gate, למשל, אנחנו
מצליחים להפעיל T gate על מצב קלט. אבל כדי לעשות את זה, נראה שאנחנו מפעילים T gate על מצב פלוס כדי לקבל
magic state. והמצב דומה עבור מימוש ה-S gate. העניין הוא שאנחנו
לא בהכרח צריכים קודם ליצור מצב פלוס ואז להפעיל T gate כדי לקבל magic state. יש דרכים אחרות אפשריות להשיג את המצב הזה. ובפרט,
אפשר לעשות את זה בלי לדאוג לגבי הפצת שגיאות בתוך החישוב שאנחנו עובדים עליו, כי את ה-magic state-ים אפשר ליצור
בנפרד. זה מאפשר מימוש עמיד לתקלות של T gate, כמו שאתאר בקצרה עכשיו.
קודם כל, אנחנו לא באמת הולכים להריץ את circuit הפשוט של שני qubit-ים שמוצג כאן, אלא נריץ את ה-circuit הזה באמצעות
qubit-ים מקודדים בכל קוד תיקון שגיאות שאנחנו משתמשים בו למימוש העמיד לתקלות. מה שאומר שה-
gate-ים היוניטריים והמדידות נעשים על ידי gadget-ים עמידים לתקלות. וזה אומר שאנחנו גם צריכים שה-
magic state-ים שלנו יהיו מקודדים. אז הכל יהיה עמיד לתקלות כל עוד נצליח להשיג
magic state-ים מקודדים. אנחנו מניחים כאן אגב שכבר יש לנו gadget עמיד לתקלות עבור S gate. אם
היינו משתמשים בקוד Steane למשל, יכולנו פשוט לממש את ה-S gate בצורה טרנסוורסלית. ולקודים שזה לא עובד בהם, אפשרות אחת היא
קודם להשתמש בכל הסכמה הזו כדי לממש S gate בצורה עמידה לתקלות ואז להשתמש במימוש הזה כאן.
למרות שזו לא האפשרות היחידה. אבל בכל מקרה, בחזרה למימוש, השאלה החשובה שנשארת היא איך משיגים
magic state מקודד בהינתן שעדיין אין לנו מימוש עמיד לתקלות של T gate כדי ליצור את זה
בקלות? והרעיון המרכזי הוא שאפשר להשתמש בתהליך הסתברותי כדי ליצור magic state-ים מקודדים. ואם זה לא
מצליח, אז זה בסדר. אפשר פשוט לזרוק ניסיונות כושלים ולנסות שוב.
וזה לא מפריע לחישוב שאנחנו באמת מנסים לבצע כי יצירת ה-magic state-ים נעשית
בנפרד. דרך טיפוסית לעשות את זה היא באמצעות תהליך שנקרא magic state distillation. וזה עובד ככה:
יש לנו circuit מסוים שנקרא distiller. אנחנו מזינים לתוך ה-distiller הזה אוסף של magic state-ים
רועשים ואז מודדים את כל הפלטים חוץ מאחד. ואם אנחנו מתנים על כך שכל תוצאות המדידה הן אפס,
אז מה שקורה הוא שמה שיוצא הוא magic state פחות רועש, שיכול אז להיות אחד מה-qubit-ים שנכנסים
ל-distiller נוסף. והתהליך ממשיך עד שאנחנו או נכשלים כי אחת מתוצאות המדידה היא לא אפס ומנסים שוב, או שיש לנו magic
state באיכות מספיק גבוהה שאפשר להשתמש בו בבטחה כדי לממש T gate בחישוב שאכפת לנו ממנו.
יש כמה דרכים ידועות לבנות distiller כזה, אבל כולן עובדות באותו אופן בבסיסו, שהן מפענחים לקודי stabilizer,
כלומר הן הפוכות של circuit-ים מקודדים, וזה נחמד כי זה אומר שה-distiller יכול להיות פעולת Clifford.
ולבסוף, תהליך ה-distillation הזה הוא בעצם משהו שמתרחש ברמת ה-qubit הלוגי. אז במציאות, הכל
נעשה באמצעות gadget-ים עבור ה-distiller והמדידות. התהליך הזה חייב
להתחיל מאיפשהו. אבל כל עוד שיעור הרעש לא גבוה מדי, אפשר ליצור magic state-ים רועשים אבל טובים מספיק
כדי להתחיל את זה. למשל, על ידי הפעלת T gate רועש בפועל על qubit במצב פלוס ואז
קידוד ה-qubit הזה. אז זה היה תיאור ברמה מאוד גבוהה, אבל אני מקווה שנתתי לכם מושג גס איך זה עובד.
זה הרבה יותר מסובך ממימוש gate-ים בצורה טרנסוורסלית, אבל בכל זאת, זה מציע דרך לממש סט אוניברסלי של
gate-ים קוונטיים בצורה עמידה לתקלות, בעוד שמימושי gate טרנסוורסליים לבד לא יכולים לעשות את זה. לפעמים טוענים
שה-overhead של שימוש ב-magic state-ים כדי לממש gate-ים בצורה עמידה לתקלות בדרך הזו יהיה מאוד גבוה
כאשר הרוב המוחלט של העבודה הולך ל-distillation של magic state-ים והרצת החישוב עצמו היא יותר
מחשבה שנייה. אבל זה בעצם לא כל כך ברור והיו ניתוחים מפורטים שמגלים שהשיטה הזו
יכולה להיות למעשה מעשית. יש כמה סכמות ידועות נוספות למימוש gate-ים בצורה עמידה לתקלות. Code deformation ו-code switching הם שמות
שמשויכים לחלק מהסכמות האלה ודרכים חדשות ממשיכות להיות מפותחות ומשופרות אבל לא אתאר את השיטות
האלה בשיעור הזה. יש נושא חשוב נוסף הקשור למימושים עמידים לתקלות של circuit-ים קוונטיים וזה
נוגע לשלבי תיקון השגיאות עצמם. אז זה לא על מימוש gate-ים. זה על ביצוע
תיקון השגיאות בפועל. הבעיה היא שאם נחשוב על ה-circuit-ים הפשוטים שראינו
לראשונה בשיעור 14 למדידת מחוללי stabilizer על בסיס הערכת פאזה, נגלה שהם לא
עמידים לתקלות בעצמם כי הם עלולים לגרום לשגיאות להתפשט בתוך בלוק קוד יחיד.
זה חוזר לרעיון שכל דבר שקשור למידע קוונטי רגיש לשגיאות וזה כולל את ה-circuit-ים שנועדו בעצמם
לתקן שגיאות. זה נשמע די בעייתי, אבל יש למעשה כמה פתרונות ידועים לבעיה הזו. אזכיר רק כמה מהם,
למרות שלא אסביר אף אחד מהם בפירוט. ואגב, אם אתם מקבלים את הרושם שמחשוב קוונטי עמיד לתקלות הוא
מסובך ויש הרבה פרטים שצריך לדאוג לגביהם, אז זה בהחלט מובן כי זה נכון. יש הרבה חלקים נעים
כאן והכוונה שלי בשיעור הזה היא לא להסביר את כל הפרטים אלא לתת לכם רק הקדמה בסיסית לאיך הכל
עובד. שיטה אחת לתיקון שגיאות קוונטי עמיד לתקלות ידועה בשם Shor error correction על שם Peter
Shor שהציע את השיטה הזו ראשון. הרעיון הוא לבצע כל מדידת סינדרום באמצעות מה שנקרא cat state,
שזה אותו דבר כמו מצב GHZ כשיש לנו שלושה qubit-ים, אבל אפשר להכליל את זה לכל מספר של qubit-ים שמתאים למשקל של מחולל ה-stabilizer
שאנחנו מתכוונים למדוד. בפרט, ה-circuit שמוצג כאן עובד למדידת מחולל stabilizer. ואפשר להראות
שהשיטה הזו לא גורמת לשגיאות להתפשט בתוך בלוק קוד.
היא מצריכה יצירת ה-cat state עצמו. וכדי שזה יעבוד באופן אמין בנוכחות שגיאות ו-gate-ים שעלולים להיות תקולים, השיטה בעצם
דורשת שנריץ שוב ושוב circuit-ים כאלה ונסיק לגבי היכן שגיאות שונות אולי קרו במהלך
התהליך. שיטה חלופית ידועה בשם Steane error correction שהוצעה לראשונה על ידי Andrew Steane וזו
שיטה שעובדת אחרת והיא עובדת רק עבור קודי CSS. בשיטה הזו, אנחנו לא באמת מבצעים את מדידות הסינדרום על המצבים הקוונטיים
המקודדים ב-circuit שאנחנו מנסים להריץ, אלא במכוון מפיצים שגיאות למערכת עבודה
ואז מודדים את המערכת הזו ומזהים שגיאות באופן קלאסי. האיור המוצג כאן מראה איך לעשות את זה עבור שגיאות X, שבמקרה הזה qubit-י
העבודה מאותחלים לקידוד של מצב פלוס. אז זה בעצם
מימוש טרנסוורסלי של C-NOT gate שלא אמור לעשות כלום כי המטרה במצב פלוס. אבל אם היו
שגיאות X ב-qubit-ים העליונים, הן יתפשטו למטה למערכת התחתונה והן יזוהו. יש גם שיטה דומה לזיהוי שגיאות Z
והיא לא מוצגת כאן. יש גם שיטה קשורה שנקראת Knill error correction שהוצעה לראשונה על ידי Manny Knill
והיא מבוססת על טלפורטציה במקום C-NOT טרנסוורסלי וזה מאפשר לה לעבוד עבור קודי stabilizer
שרירותיים ולא רק קודי CSS.
הדבר האחרון שאדבר עליו בשיעור הזה הוא משפט חשוב מאוד שנקרא משפט הסף. הנה ניסוח לא
פורמלי של המשפט. הוא אומר שאם יש לנו circuit קוונטי כלשהו עם n gate-ים כאשר n יכול להיות גדול ככל שנרצה, אז אפשר
לממש את ה-circuit הזה ברמת דיוק גבוהה באמצעות circuit קוונטי רועש בתנאי שרמת הרעש
נמצאת מתחת לערך סף מסוים שלא תלוי ב-n. ויתרה מזאת, זה לא יקר מדי לעשות את זה במובן
שהגודל של ה-circuit הרועש הנדרש הוא בסדר גודל של n כפול חזקה קבועה כלשהי של הלוגריתם של
n. כדי לנסח את המשפט בצורה יותר פורמלית צריך להיות ספציפיים לגבי מודל הרעש, מה שלא אעשה בשיעור הזה.
אפשר למשל להוכיח את זה עבור מודל הרעש הסטוכסטי הבלתי תלוי שהזכרתי קודם שבו שגיאות מתרחשות
באופן בלתי תלוי בכל מיקום אפשרי ב-circuit עם הסתברות כלשהי שקטנה ממש מערך הסף הזה. אבל אפשר גם
להוכיח את זה עבור מודלי רעש כלליים יותר שבהם יכולות להיות קורלציות בין שגיאות. עכשיו, זו תוצאה
תיאורטית והדרך הטיפוסית שבה מוכיחים אותה לא בהכרח מתרגמת למשהו שהיינו עושים בפועל, אבל עדיין זהו משפט מאוד
חשוב מבחינה מעשית. והסיבה לכך היא שהוא בעצם אומר שאין מחסום יסודי לביצוע
חישובים קוונטיים באמצעות רכיבים רועשים.
כל עוד שיעור השגיאות של הרכיבים האלה נמצא מתחת לערך הסף הזה, אפשר להשתמש בהם כדי לבנות circuit-ים קוונטיים אמינים בגודל
שרירותי. דרך אחרת לומר את זה היא שאם המשפט לא היה נכון, קשה לדמיין שמחשוב קוונטי בקנה מידה גדול
היה הופך למציאות אי פעם. יש הרבה פרטים טכניים שמעורבים בהוכחות פורמליות של המשפט הזה, שלא אנסה
להעביר. אבל אנסה להסביר את הרעיון הבסיסי ברמה גבוהה. וגם אנסה לקשר באופן רופף את הרעיון
הבסיסי למה שנצפה שיקרה בפועל. אז בואו נניח שזה ה-circuit שלנו. זה אותו circuit שדיברנו
עליו כל השיעור. אבל שוב, אפשר לדמיין שה-circuit שלנו הרבה יותר גדול ומסובך מזה. אנחנו רוצים
לממש את ה-circuit הזה, אבל כל הרכיבים שלנו רועשים. ובהנחה שאנחנו משתמשים במודל הרעש הסטוכסטי הבלתי תלוי
רק לשם פשטות, יש הסתברות P כלשהי שבה שגיאות מתרחשות באופן בלתי תלוי בכל מיקום אפשרי.
אם ה-circuit היה גדול משמעותית מההופכי של ההסתברות P הזו, אז היינו יכולים להיות די בטוחים שמימוש
ישיר שלו לא יעבוד נכון. אז אנחנו עוברים את כל העניין של מימוש ה-circuit
בצורה עמידה לתקלות כמו שדנתי עד לנקודה הזו בשיעור ושואלים את עצמנו את השאלה שהעליתי קודם, האם אנחנו משפרים דברים
או מחמירים אותם? ובכן, אם ההסתברות P שמייצגת את הסתברות השגיאה של כל אחד מהרכיבים שלנו גדולה מדי אז
זה לא יעזור, בדיוק כמו שקוד Shor של 9 qubit-ים לא עוזר אם הסתברות השגיאה מעל 3 ורבע אחוז בערך.
בפרט, עכשיו הגדלנו את ה-circuit. אז יש הרבה יותר מיקומים שבהם שגיאות יכולות לפגוע.
עם זאת, אם P קטן מספיק, זה הולך לעזור. ומה שנעשה למעשה הוא להפחית את הסתברות
השגיאה עבור החישוב הלוגי שאנחנו מבצעים. אז בואו נחשוב על זה
קצת יותר לעומק. וכדי לראות את הרעיונות המרכזיים בהגדרה הכי פשוטה שאפשר, בואו נניח שאנחנו משתמשים בקוד Steane של 7 qubit-ים לתיקון
שגיאות, שמאפשר תיקון של עד שגיאה אחת לכל בלוק קוד. אז כדי ששגיאה לוגית
תתרחש ב-circuit המקורי, יצטרכו להיות לפחות שתי שגיאות שנופלות לאותו בלוק קוד במימוש העמיד
לתקלות שלנו.
בהתחשב בכך שיש הרבה דרכים שונות שבהן שתי שגיאות או יותר יכולות ליפול באותו בלוק קוד, אפשר לטעון שההסתברות לשגיאה לוגית
בכל מיקום ב-circuit המקורי היא לכל היותר C כפול P בריבוע כאשר C הוא מספר שתלוי בקוד וב-
gadget-ים שאנחנו משתמשים בהם. אבל באופן קריטי, הוא לא תלוי בגודל ה-circuit המקורי.
אז אם P קטן מההופכי של C, שהוא המספר שאפשר לקחת כערך הסף שלנו, אז זה
מתרגם להפחתת שגיאה. אז העבודה הקשה שלנו במימוש ה-circuit בצורה עמידה לתקלות משתלמת.
עם זאת, שיעור השגיאות החדש הזה עדיין עלול להיות גבוה מדי כדי שכל ה-circuit יעבוד נכון. אז צריך לעשות
יותר. בפועל, דבר טבעי לעשות בנקודה הזו הוא לבחור קוד טוב יותר ו-gadget-ים טובים יותר כדי להוריד את שיעור השגיאות
לנקודה שבה סביר שהמימוש יעבוד.
מבחינה תיאורטית, דרך פשוטה לטעון שזה אפשרי היא שרשור. במילים אחרות, אנחנו חושבים
על המימוש העמיד לתקלות של ה-circuit המקורי כ-circuit לוגי חדש. ואז מממשים אותו בצורה עמידה
לתקלות. ואז עושים את זה שוב ושוב כמה פעמים שצריך. ומתברר שזה מפחית את השגיאה
מאוד מהר. וככה משפט הסף בדרך כלל מוכח על הנייר.
אתן לכם רק מושג מאוד גס לגבי איך שיעור השגיאות יורד, בלי הרבה פרטים טכניים שנדרשים כדי
להוכיח את זה פורמלית. אנחנו מתחילים עם הסתברות השגיאה P עבור הרכיבים המקוריים שלנו. ואם מממשים את
ה-circuit בצורה עמידה לתקלות, השגיאה יורדת בגורם של C כפול P. אם אז מתייחסים למימוש העמיד
לתקלות כ-circuit לוגי ומממשים אותו בצורה עמידה לתקלות, מקבלים ירידה דומה בשיעור השגיאות. אבל
אם חושבים על שיעור השגיאות האפקטיבי עבור ה-circuit המקורי, מגלים שהוא יורד עוד יותר כי עכשיו
אנחנו מחליפים את שיעור השגיאות P ב-C כפול P בריבוע כי זה שיעור השגיאות האפקטיבי אחרי הרמה הראשונה של מימוש עמיד
לתקלות. ספציפית, אחרי קצת אלגברה, מגלים שהשגיאה יורדת ל-CP
בשלישית כפול P. ואם עושים את זה שוב, עכשיו יש לנו שיעור שגיאות של CP בחזקת 7 כפול P. ואם
ממשיכים לעשות את זה לסך הכל K רמות, מה שמגלים הוא שהשגיאה מתכווצת באופן אקספוננציאלי כפול ב-K. אז לא
צריך לעשות את זה הרבה פעמים כדי להוריד את שיעור השגיאות לרמה מאוד קטנה.
בינתיים, ה-circuit-ים גדלים, אבל הגודל עולה רק באופן אקספוננציאלי יחיד ב-K כי עם כל
רמה של עמידות לתקלות, גודל ה-circuit שלנו גדל לכל היותר בגורם שנקבע על ידי הגודל המקסימלי של
ה-gadget-ים שלנו. וכשמרכיבים את הכל ובוחרים מספר מתאים
של רמות שרשור, מקבלים את משפט הסף. אבל כמו שכבר רמזתי, יש הרבה פרטים שנדרשים כדי להפוך את זה לפורמלי. אז
מה הוא ערך הסף הזה במציאות? ובכן, זה תלוי בקוד וב-gadget-ים שאנחנו
משתמשים בהם. עבור קוד Steane יחד עם magic state distillation, הוא זעיר וכנראה לא בר השגה
בפועל. אבל באמצעות surface codes ו-gadget-ים מתקדמים ביותר, הוא הוערך בסביבות 1%. וזה לא
רע. וככל שקודים ושיטות חדשים מתגלים, סביר לצפות שהוא יעלה ובמקביל
רמת הרעש ברכיבים שאנחנו בונים תרד. להגיע לנקודה שבה
חישובים קוונטיים בקנה מידה גדול יוכלו להתבצע בצורה עמידה לתקלות לא יהיה קל וזה לא יקרה בן לילה.
אבל המשפט הזה יחד עם ההתקדמות בקודים קוונטיים ובחומרה קוונטית שראינו עד כה
נותנים לנו את האופטימיות שאנחנו צריכים כדי להמשיך לדחוף קדימה ולהגיע למטרה הסופית של בניית
מחשב קוונטי עמיד לתקלות בקנה מידה גדול. וזהו סוף השיעור וסוף הסדרה. אני
באמת מקווה שמצאתם ערך בסדרה ואם כן, אנא שקלו להמליץ עליה לעמית או חבר.
כמו כן, בדקו את IBM Quantum Learning לקורסים ומדריכים נוספים, והירשמו לערוץ ה-Qiskit
ביוטיוב אם עדיין לא עשיתם את זה, כדי שתוכלו להישאר מעודכנים עם התכנים העתידיים שלנו. תודה
שצפיתם.